c'est david saint-jacques vous avez
décidé bonsoir vous avez décidé de
revenir aux sources
voyant les besoins énormes dans le même
temps le réseau de la santé et de
travailler comme métier comment ça se
fait ce pas là pour un astronaute quand
même énorme
oui bah écoutez je vais mais sa cote est
depuis longtemps l'idée de peut-être
revenir à la pratique qui n'est qu'à ça
fait presque
et puis avec la fin des milliers des
besoins énormes et par des années
j'entends parler des demandes du besoin
de volontaires comme médecin pour
travailler sur les unités que vides
je me suis renseigné auprès du collège
des médecins puis un processus là pour
reprendre si on veut la certification
donc le chapitre des revenus un peu
comme un expert en fait le seul système
médical je suis sur une équipe une
équipe qui couvrait une technique alors
c'est vraiment des équipes formidables
donc j'ai repris le travail médical la
pente était raide mais au moins on dit
ça fait du bien d'aider donc 900 ma
place là contribuer
on a vu de très belles photos pas si
vous avez pratiqué dans le grand nord
vous pratiquez vous vous étiez votre
spécialité getti généralise dans les
zones éloignées
c'est ça oui je t'aime telle famille est
là quand vous dites je dois me remettre
à ce que ça vaut jusqu'à vous reprenez
la lecture des manuels d après dix ans
comment ça fonctionne concrètement la
beauté des choses qui ne changent pas
l'être humain une charge pour les la
plupart des maladies ne change pas mais
les médicaments change les systèmes
répartis système informatique ne
m'entendrez d'hôpitaux avait donc tout
ce côté là aussi à réapprendre les soins
d'urgence et des protocoles qui ont
changé donc les réflexes a appris des
choses qui reviennent un peu comme faire
durer les choses qu'il faut tout changer
il faut pour réapprendre mais c'est peu
c'est ce fait comme ça en enseignement
ils sont habitués on avait les milieux
de werther pour comprendre aussi que
pour les une pique au vif une com gère
une foule de médecins et d'infirmières
de tous les horizons qu'il n'ya pas
volontaire donc comme une atmosphère
collégiale il ya des fraudeurs et
chirurgie cardiaque qui viennent faire
ce que je fais des gens qui ont passé
souvent les autres non plus donc il ya
tout comme un esprit de collaboration
dans cette maladie qui est vraiment
belle à voir et vous vouliez vous teniez
à léo seront vous c'est clair oui c'est
un peu une question de personnalité moi
je dors mieux en tirer
même si c'est un petit aux jeunes un
putois retour à la facture est à prendre
très fermé de georges dor mua car j'ai
l'impression que contribuer de manière
concrète à faire est la solution pour ce
catastrophe qu'on dit q qu'est ce que
vous allez faire dont vous allez
pratiquer ou le savez vous mais en ce
moment je suis au centre albert fert
mais guy les dépasser acolytes sont tous
concentrés dans cette grisaille pour
protéger le reste m hospitalier le
personnel aussi est concentrée dans les
ailes de coved donc je suis sûr fait
douter leur rotation avec avec d'autres
et vos premières impressions de la du
moral des troupes sur le front reprenant
l'image du franc de cette guerre contre
la pandémie
quelles sont vos premières impressions
de vos collègues vous avez revu que vous
voyez que vous rencontrez alors comme
tout le monde les médecins et
d'infirmières crois que ça finisse levée
de ces pas de mec savoir tenir et on se
sent très bien organisés pour réussir à
faire leur travail malgré les
contraintes de protection personnelle
énorme hein donc on est constamment
présence de patients activement malades
dont il ya tout un protocole à ses
règlements
si on le fait on a un ça va bien on est
passé j'ai donc il ya une tension sa
manutention lourdeur toujours ce besoin
de fortement affecté selecter se changer
ramette un nouveau rythme à chaque
patient ça mais il y aussi un
il ya une tristesse dans tout ça que
c'est tous ces médecins infirmières par
ailleurs spécialisé ne feront plus était
avant l'heure leur passion pour
constater surtout vide tout le monde
déplore évidemment qui rend à paris
beaucoup ces temps ci mais liste
d'attenté qui s'allongent et plein de
gens en attente sont trop peut-être pour
besoin de soins urgents mais quand même
des choses graves qui sont constamment
repoussée donc il ya une tristesse à
avoir tout ce qu'on ne fait pas en un
monstre bord contre la contre lacko vide
mais il ya vraiment un esprit pas l'état
les gens se serrent les coudes ça c'est
trop beau à voir c'est vraiment des
veaux maxime que je suis fier de me
santi de quoi mais c'est bien entendre
tu avais de saint jacques en terminant
votre relation avec le temps comme
astronaute et très précises
vous savez combien de temps vous allez
tourner autour de la terre
j'avais combien de temps ça va vous
prendre pour partir de la terre pour
aller à la station orbitale et c'est là
savez vous combien de temps vous allez
aller comme ça au front nom de ce poids
là les retours au cas par cas
donc le matin je vais rester comme ça
certains plusieurs semaines va partir et
le qui pleure et puis j'aime a continué
à long terme tant qu attendait me tuera
à faire faire ma part c'est je pense le
prêt portant de prendre la chance le
temps est ce qu'il y aura un prix à
payer pour votre carrière d'astronaute
non oui c'est ça qui considère que ces
planètes mandarin est quand même au bout
du compte un fonctionnaire donc
fondamentalement au service de la
population
tu avais de saint jacques c'est toujours
un plaisir merci beaucoup bonne suite ne
serait beaucoup merci de nous avoir est
payant on va s'en sortir
oui oui quand même on ne connaît pas le
fait pas le temps baissé c'est pas tant
baissé la garde
très bien
david saint-jacques merci au revoir
ouais